I really do think it's fair to say that  Wednesday will be one of the worst days  of Abby Lee Miller's life the forward  Dance Moms star is due to report to the  federal prison in Victorville California  tomorrow but I want you to check out  this brand-new video because until she  has to go  Abby is living her life this was Abby  last night all smiles out for some fine  dining before checking herself into  federal prison tomorrow we are you  mentally prepared for Wednesday swarmed  by paparazzi at Hollywood hotspot  Craig's Abby Lee seems to be enjoying  the attention stopping for selfies on  her way to the car just don't ask for an  autograph it's as if she's actually  looking forward to serving time for  bankruptcy fraud one year in one day  can't hold you down there be you know  that joke about it's very serious and  I'm doing was accepted but afternoon  [Music]